our Kevin Frazier is at the Grammy
Museum in L.A you know I love a music
moment Kev exciting day uh it's a
record-setting day also Nichelle we have
all the snubs surprises and praise but
as you know the Party begins and ends
with Beyonce
it feels good to know that the hard work
paid off Beyonce it was so monumental
Beyonce breaking records leading today's
pack with nine nods Mr and Mrs Carter
are also now the Grammys king and queen
with 88 nominations the most in history
as girl power dominated the record of
the Year category
Adele nominated too and we remember the
last time these two went head to head I
can't wait to see what happens this year
we are again Taylor Swift is feeling
Vindicated today grabbing a song of the
year nod for a track she originally
released in 2012. you gave them a 10
minute long recording of All Too Well
people's symbolism it's just a lot of a
lot and speaking of redemption
Machine Gun Kelly got his first Nom
after last year's snub had him firing
off what the bleep is wrong with the
Grammys that was just last year's tweet
it's been those tweets have happened for
10 years for sure just the envelope with
where they read my name on it I'm a
hoarder so this is going to stay in my
house I'd like to thank the academy he
got winner and soon to be dad of three
John Legend knows all about Awards he
scored three knobs today do the kids in
the family get excited to call you and
congratulate Daddy I don't think my kids
know what a Grammy is yeah I'll have to
explain it to him maybe I'll explain it
to him today all that pumping up your
chest some Shockers after Drake Made
boycott the Grammys headlines he wound
up nominated for various collabs and
Nicki Minaj got snubbed after calling
out the organization for labeling her
rap song pop big question who's gonna
host could Trevor be back he could we'll
know more in the next few weeks will you
perform at the Grammys yes Grammys I
will be performing at the Grammys I'm
inviting myself I know where you live
live